das richtige maß die zweite corona welle
muss gebrochen werden das wird immer
klarer über die nötigen beschränkungen
aber herrscht seit warnung der ärzte
klinikbetten für cupid patienten gibt es
noch genug aber bei den pflegekräften
könnte es bald eng werden antibiotika im
stall bei stichproben war gut jedes
zweite discounter hähnchen mit keimen
belastet die oft sogar multiresistent
waren
die nachrichten des tages heute mit
petra gerster guten abend willkommen wie
heute an diesem dienstag sven voss hat
den sport dabei in gut einer
viertelstunde schon genannt die zweite
infektionswelle rechtzeitig brechen
damit die pandemie nicht außer kontrolle
gerät das scheint das gebot der stunde
morgen schon könnte es deshalb neue und
auch bundesweite einschränkungen geben
denn die zahlen die das
robert-koch-institut täglich
zusammenstellt verheißen nichts gutes
die karte der brennpunkte tiefrot 11.400
neun neue infizierte werden von den
gesundheitsämtern aktuell gemeldet und
aus der bundesregierung heißt es dass
schon ende der woche täglich 20.000 neue
fälle dazukommen könnten
das befeuert die debatte über eine
corona notbremse wie die aussehen könnte
wollen bund und länder morgen besprechen
aus berlin thomas reichert rottal inn
hat die reißleine gezogen und einen
locker und verfügt die zahl der
neuinfektionen pro 100.000 einwohnern in
den letzten sieben tagen lag bei 239
es gelten ausgangs beschränkungen
restaurants schulen kindergärten müssen
schließen auf straßen geht masten
pflicht in rottal-inn es passiert was
anderswo vermieden werden soll mit einer
verschärfung der korona regeln
heute warnt merkel auf einer video
konferenz wir sehen auch bei den
steigenden zahlen dass wenn da das was
wir wissen über das virus nicht
einhalten
dass wir dann wieder in situationen
kommen die ausgesprochen schwierig sind
wissenschaftler der leopoldina fordern
heute schnelle und deutliche
verschärfungen einen auf zwei drei
wochen befristeten lockern will spd
gesundheitsexperte lauterbach
wenn wir jetzt nicht so etwas machen wir
an so genannten wellenbrecher shutdown
womit wir diese welle die jetzt auf uns
zu durchbrechen
dann sind wir in wenigen wochen dem
kompletten lockdown sowie im frühjahr
wieder was genau morgen beschlossen wird
es noch nicht klar aber auch länder wie
sachsen-anhalt vollziehen angesichts der
infektionszahlen eine art kurswende
tritt nun für
einheitliche lösungen ein wir werden auf
jeden fall eine nationale lösung
mittragen
und wir haben natürlich dazu beitragen
dass sie mit augenmaß so gefällt wird
dass die effekte die wir erwarten
nämlich eindämmung und reduzierung der
infektionen dass das auch wirklich
erreicht wird hoffen aber ist ob alle
länder weitgehende kontakt
beschränkungen wollen wie
nordrhein-westfalen sie fordert die lage
ist sehr sehr ernst und die bisher
geltenden maßnahmen reichen offenkundig
nicht aus um diesen trend zu stoppen
und deshalb kommt es jetzt auf ein
beherztes dieser ernsten lage
angemessenes handeln der politik an die
opposition dagegen fordert vor dem
treffen im kanzleramt mehr transparenz
und mehr mitsprache für das parlament
tja da scheint ja mächtig dampf im
kessel zu sein schalk unter ben ali in
berlin
wie groß ist denn die chance dass die
länder diesmal an einem strang ziehen
also man kann auf jeden fall sagen dass
der druck schon lange nicht mehr so groß
gewesen ist die zahlen sind schlecht die
adventszeit naht und jetzt steht die
frage im raum wie stabilisiert man die
lage bis weihnachten so dass die
menschen auf weihnachten feiern können
so wie sie das gerne machen würden
die bisherigen maßnahmen greifen ja
nicht so wie von bund und ländern
gehofft jetzt ist die große frage welche
maßnahmen werden den wirksam und würden
zugleich wirtschaft und bildung schonen
und nicht zu sehr in grundrechte
eingreifen wenn man sich so anhört was
an vorschlägen auf dem tisch liegt dann
kann man sagen dass es morgen fast keine
tabus geben wird da wird wahrscheinlich
über alles gesprochen von schärferen
kontakt beschränkungen über neue
maßnahmen für schulen oder auch
grenzschließungen alles kann diskutiert
werden
die große frage ist eben gibt es am ende
da eine einigkeit und eine klare lösung
die auch als signal verstanden wird oder
nicht das ist momentan noch völlig offen
vielen dank und nach berlin bei den
schnell steigenden neuansteckungen
fragen sich viele wie lange unser
gesundheitssystem dem druck standhalten
kann
ein gradmesser ist für experten die
anzahl der freien intensivbetten vor gut
zwei wochen lagen 590 corona infizierte
auf den
die stationen jetzt sind es bereits 1469
mehr als doppelt so viele 7655
intensivbetten sind noch frei an seinem
stern berichtet auf sie kommt es an
mediziner und pflegekräfte vorderste
front die intensivstationen wie hier im
antonius hospital in eschweiler bei
aachen
sie kämpfen um das leben ihrer patienten
immer wieder auch um das leben von kogit
patienten eine extremsituation auch für
bernd rütten seit 30 jahren im dienst
als intensivpfleger jetzt einen ganz
netten älteren herrn der leider auch
heute verstorben ist jetzt habe ich
schon sorgen ja weil die fallzahlen er
insgesamt höher sind
wir sind insgesamt zwar besser gewappnet
und wir wissen auch was auf uns zukommt
aber ich bin so eine innerliche unruhe
ist schon letztendlich da unruhe mehr
virus patienten aber noch sind viele
betten frei und die deutschen
krankenhäuser haben zusätzliche
notfallreserve weitere 12.000 700 betten
könnten aufgestellt werden
material ist also da ist fehlt das
personal und zwar bis zu 4000 intensiv
pflegekräfte warnen mediziner
hier müssen langfristige konzepte
getroffen werden wie wir das endlich in
den griff bekommen und ohne
pflegepersonal ohne die menschen die
patienten direkt betreuen können wir
tolle medizin machen wie wir wollen
da können wir den menschen irgendwann
nicht mehr helfen das ist meine größte
sorge
wir werden in einer akuten
personalmangel hineinlaufen wir jetzt
nicht etwas tun wir schulen deswegen
schon anderes krankenhauspersonal damit
es diese funktion übernehmen kann aber
das sind alles nur hilfsmittel
hilfsmittel wie schutzkleidung und
beatmungsgeräte sind ausreichend
vorhanden sagen die kliniken
das aber ist nicht viel wert wenn es an
ihnen fehlt fachkräfte die an vorderster
front kämpfen in dieser virus krise die
bilder von überfüllten intensivstationen
sind den menschen in italien noch
deutlich vor augen
jetzt die zweite welle und wieder gelten
harte einschränkungen
dagegen gingen vergangenen nacht
in mehreren städten tausende auf die
straßen ihre wut entlud sich auch in
gewalt es flogen steine und flaschen
die polizei setzte tränengas ein viele
italiener fürchten den wirtschaftlichen
niedergang durch die korona beschränkung
der kampf gegen korona hierzulande oder
auch bei unseren nachbarn in europa die
aktuellen entwicklungen können sie
jederzeit bei uns in corona blog
nachlesen in der cs heute app wie afg im
brandenburger landtag hat einen neuen
vorsitzenden
die fraktion wählte hans christoph
berndt zu ihrem neuen chef
der 64 jährige leitet den verein zukunft
heimat den der verfassungsschutz als
rechtsextremistisch einstuft bernd ist
nachfolger von andreas kalbitz der im
mai aus der partei ausgeschlossen worden
war
er soll kontakte ins
rechtsextremistischen milieu
verschwiegen haben
da scheint die afg in brandenburg ja ein
politiker mit ganz ähnlicher gesinnung
wie kalbitz gewählt zu haben oder nicht
nun es war eine wahl zwischen drei
extremisten mit hans christoph berndt
hat die fraktion einen wie sie sagt
klugen kopf und guten rhetoriker gewählt
der landesverfassungsschutz chef hier
bezeichnet ihn aber als klaren
rechtsextremisten sein verein heimat
zukunft heimat organisiert regelmäßig
demonstrationen und kundgebungen gegen
flüchtlinge und jüngst auch gegen korona
zudem gilt er als verbündeter als
kalbitz loyaler getreue
er war jüngst noch einmal mit ihm
zusammen auf einer päda veranstaltung
und zudem muss man muss man sagen dass
der landesverfassungsschutz diesen
verein schon lange beobachtet und auch
weiter beobachten wird heute nachmittag
habe ich mit fraktionsmitgliedern
gesprochen sie haben gesagt das sei vor
allem heute eine wahl gewesen um
geschlossenheit zu demonstrieren und das
wiederum ist ein klares signal an die
bunt
fd nehme ich das signal das man in
brandenburg weiter rechts außen bleiben
wird vielen dank für diese
hintergrundinformation nicola albrecht
in potsdam in belarus versucht die
opposition weiter mit einem
generalstreik das land lahmzulegen
viele menschen demonstrieren auf den
straßen noch immer gegen machthaber
lukaschenko die sicherheitskräfte
reagieren weiterhin mit festnahmen rund
600 waren es laut innenministerium
alleine gestern präsident lukaschenko
sprach im staatsfernsehen von
terroristischen zügen die die proteste
annehmen
die opposition betont ihr widerstand sei
friedlich und auch in polen proteste
viele frauen sind auf den barrikaden
seit tagen demonstrieren sie gegen die
nationalkonservative regierung und gegen
das oberste gericht denn das hat
entschieden dass abtreibung auch bei
schwerer fehlbildung des fötus verboten
ist und folgte damit dem antrag von
abgeordneten der regierungspartei aus
warschau natalie steger
sie blockieren die straßen bis in die
letzte nacht hinein demonstrieren polens
frauen gegen eine verschärfung des
abtreibungsrechts den fünften tag in
folge und zuletzt laut polnischen
medienberichten in mehr als 100 städten
wir werden ins mittelalter zurück
geworfen es ist ganz furchtbar weil es
uns alle betrifft alle frauen
ich habe ein kleines kind deshalb kann
ich nicht jeden tag kommen aber ich
schicke meinen mann wenn ich keine zeit
haben das polnische verfassungsgericht
auf nationalkonservative regierungslinie
hatte abtreibung im falle von schwerster
fehlbildung des fötus als
verfassungswidrig verboten
polen hat ohnehin eines der strengsten
abtreibungsgesetze heute im sale tumulte
parlamentarierin
in der opposition demonstrieren empört
sicherheitskräfte werden gerufen
die regierungspartei peace die seit
jahren abtreibung erschweren möchte
bleibt bei ihrer linie
wir schützen das leben deshalb
appelliere ich an alle die das recht
brechen und wieder sammeln sie sich
rouven für morgen zum generalstreik auf
vor vier jahren war die pis
zurückgerudert mit einem schärferen
abtreibungsrecht damals wegen tagelanger
riesiger frauen protest us-präsident
trump und seiner republikaner können
einen sieg feiern wenige tage vor der
präsidentenwahl der senat hat gegen den
widerstand der demokraten amy kunibert
als verfassungsrichterin bestätigt damit
haben die konservativen am obersten
gericht eine klare mehrheit wichtig bei
gesellschaftspolitischen streit themen
wie abtreibung oder krankenversicherung
und wenn es möglicherweise um die
gültigkeit von wahlergebnissen geht
ines trams berichtet gross das spektakel
präsident trump feiert seinen triumph
emi kunibert im eilverfahren hat er sie
durchgesetzt als neue richterin am
supreme court auf den letzten metern vor
der wahl will er damit punkten bei
konservativen vielleicht auch bei frauen
ist die allererste mutter von
schulpflichtigen kindern die
verfassungsrichterin wird sehr wichtig
48 jährige juristin siebenfache mutter
erzkonservativ und strenggläubige
katholikin erneut betont sie ohne eine
agenda anzutreten
ich werde meine aufgabe ohne angst oder
gunst wahrnehmen unabhängig von der
politik und meinen eigenen vorliegen
gegen das recht auf abtreibung ist
bereit für waffen besitzen gegen eine
staatliche krankenversicherung über die
das gericht anfang november berät eine
neue konservative mehrheit am supreme
court von nun 6 zu 3 wird zementiert
richter werden auf lebenszeit berufen
die demokraten im senat wollten
entsprechen die
die berufung aufschieben bis nach der
wahl doch die mehrheit der republikaner
setzte berit durch diese entscheidung
bedeutet eine konservative wende in der
amerikanischen rechtssprechung werries
berufung wird trumps präsidentschaft
lange überdauern
obamas gesundheitsreform das recht auf
abtreibung und gleichgeschlechtliche
partnerschaft könnten gekippt werden
auch den ausgang der wahl könnte berit
beeinflussen streitfälle zum wahlrecht
und eventuell auch zum ergebnis könnte
sie möglicherweise bald mit zu
entscheiden haben jetzt zu einer gefahr
für unsere gesundheit jenseits von
corona es geht um resistente keime
solche also gegen die gängige
antibiotika nicht mehr helfen
sie entstehen auch in der
massentierhaltung bei hühnern etwa und
geraten so in unsere nahrung das zdf
magazin frontal 21 berichtet heute über
eine studie in mehreren eu ländern
untersucht wurde hähnchenfleisch von
discountern in gut der hälfte der proben
wurden resistente keime gefunden
thomas münten insgesamt 165 proben bei
aldi nord und lidl in deutschland polen
frankreich den niederlanden und spanien
nahm die mitarbeiter der
umweltorganisation germanwatch
die höchste belastung hatten dabei die
fleisch pakete die die deutsche phw
gruppe zu der auch wiesenhof gehört für
aldi und lidl packt 59 prozent der
getesteten fleischstücke waren mit
multiresistenten keimen belastet 25
prozent mit dem gefährlichen
krankenhauskeim mrsa er marissa sind
deswegen ein besonderes ergebnis weil
sie relativ selten ansonsten auf
hähnchen proben gefunden kann er marissa
ist ja ein bekannter multiresistenter
schwer zu therapieren da kein der
wundinfektion verursachen kann aber auch
lungenentzündungen verantwortlich dafür
ist der hohe antibiotika einsatz in der
geflügelhaltung
bundeslandwirtschaftsministerin julia
klöckner verhandelt darüber schon seit
zwei jahren
der deutsche geflügel verband aber bis
zu die ministerin nicht kompromissbereit
das ganze war nicht sehr dynamisch nach
vorne lösungsorientiert um es kurz zu
sagen und das will ich ändern
die discounter verweist auf die
geflügelhalter die für sie produzieren
deren zentralverband der deutschen
geflügelwirtschaft will kein interview
geben schriftlich heißt es dass die
tiere weiter mit antibiotika behandelt
werden müssten um die tiergesundheit zu
sichern
hersteller und verkäufer raten nochmals
geflügelfleisch nur durchgegart zu
verzieren
mehr zu diesem thema in frontal21 heute
um 21 uhr beim verpackungsmüll liegt
deutschland an der spitze europas und
die zahlen steigen weiter die
abfallmenge wuchs laut umweltbundesamt
2018 auf ein rekordhoch von 18,9
millionen tonnen pro kopf sind das 228
kilogramm private verbraucher
verursachten davon knapp die hälfte 47
prozent am stärksten stieg die
abfallmenge bei den verpackungen im
online-handel und nun zum sport sven und
zu einem besonderen spiel für gladbach
tja denn es heißt champions league im
borussia-park real madrid ist heute zu
gast vor 35 jahren gab es dieses duell
zuletzt damals wie heute ist der
spanische rekordmeister favorit doch im
gegensatz zu gladbach ist real noch
punktlos und deshalb schon unter druck
sie sind gekommen um zu gewinnen
gezwungenermaßen nach der niederlage zum
auftakt gegen den jetzt natürlich
betonen toni kroos wir nur spanischen
medien sei der druck jetzt groß und dies
bereits ein endspiel
komfortabler hat da momente borussia die
zuletzt auch rückstände wegsteckte erst
in mailand beim 2 2 bei inter dann beim
3 2 am wochenende in mainz marco rose
arbeit anerkannt auch in madrid ich
glaube dass sie sich sehr gut entwickelt
haben glaube ich dass das der trainer
sehr gut eingeschlagen hat letztes jahr
35 jahre ist es her dass die borussia im
europacup zuletzt auf real traf das fünf
zu eins eine demütigung für die
königlichen und doch steht trainer
heynckes damals mit seiner borussia noch
aus in madrid damals wie heute ein
besonderes spiel für beide bei denen die
ränge heute allerdings leer bleiben und
eine für den fussball ungewöhnliche
nachricht kommt heute aus norwegen der
ex fifa schiedsrichter tom harald hagen
hat sich in einem interview zu seiner
homosexualität bekannt der 44 jährige
zählt zu den bekanntesten
schiedsrichtern des landes wirklich
verheimlicht hatte tom harald hagen
seine homosexualität nie
umso überraschter zeigte er sich von den
zahlreichen reaktionen ganz besonders
auch aus der fußballbranche viele junge
spieler oder schiedsrichter auch aus
anderen sportarten haben mir nachrichten
geschickt und sich bedankt eltern haben
mir im namen ihrer kinder gedankt weil
sie wissen wie schwer es ihre kinder aus
ähnlichen gründen hatten jan aage
fjörtoft ehemaliger norwegischer stürmer
von eintracht frankfurt nennt hagen per
twitter ein vorbild und auch die
norwegische zeitung verdens gang
feiertagen thing in regenbogenfarben
thomatal tagen hat noch gesagt er habe
gar nicht mit so viel aufmerksamkeit
gerechnet dass so ein outing im
profifußball selbstverständlich wird ist
es wohl noch ein langer weg mutig und
gut wichtiger schritt
vielen dank sind beim wetter geht es
windig und nass weiter mehr dazu gleich
von ist intelli so viel von uns für den
moment mehr gibt es später im heute
journal mit bettina schausten
um drei viertel ziehen und morgen
übernimmt hier an dieser stelle
christian sievers danke ihnen für ihr
interesse und noch einen recht schönen
abend für sie es
[Musik]
ein schöner grüner ampel und herzlich
willkommen zum wetter eine stabile
wetterlage ist derzeit nicht in sicht
die luftmassen wechseln einander ab und
dann zum wochenende erreicht uns sogar
warme luft aus dem südwesten europas
in der nacht gibt es viele wolken die
von west mehr ins landesinnere ziehen es
regnet der wind kommt aus südwest und es
recht stark teilweise mit stürmischen
böen nach osten das ist erst mal trocken
an der donau
da bildet sich nebel und die
temperaturen dort bis auf null grad
minus 2 an den alpen jesus am kältesten
und im westen sind es zehn grad
morgen am vormittag muss der regen erst
einmal im osten verschwinden und auch im
süd osten lockert es auf ansonsten im
tagesverlauf im nordwesten und an der
nordsee schauer und gewitter an der
nordsee sogar stürmische böen aus
südwest und die temperaturen dazu 16
grad am oberrhein und 9 grad im südosten
häufig aber werte so um die 14 grad
die kommenden tage am donnerstag von
westen her schauer im norden gewitter
bei 9 bis 14 grad und ab freitag steigen
die temperaturen etwas an aber es bleibt
noch wechselhaft damit ein schöner abend